[Musique]
neuf ans
c'est l'âge que j'ai comme mon
instituteur se prononce mon avenir je
viens d'être convoqué pour un entretien
individuel
il s'agit de discuter des écoles que mes
parents ont choisi pour moi je suis seul
face à ce maître qui a l'habitude de se
moquer ouvertement de moi en classe
devant tous mes camarades nous sommes
début mars quelques mois avant les
examens de fin d'année
la salle dans laquelle je me trouve est
minuscule je me souviens de tout je me
souviens encore aujourd'hui de chacun de
ces mots
tu postules pour ce genre d'école
regarde toi jamais aucune institution
digne de ce nom ne voudra de quelqu'un
comme toi
il est vrai que je suis ce que l'on
appelle un mauvais élève tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est embêter mes camarades
cacher leurs affaires et surtout imité
la signature de ma mère et ce
particulièrement amusant puisque elle
est institutrice
je m'ennuie à l'école profondément et je
dois concentrer le trop plein d'énergie
qui bouillonne en moi pour me focaliser
sur des sujets absolument inintéressant
à mes yeux je me sens complètement en
décalage il m'est impossible de prendre
cela au sérieux je collectionne les
mauvaise note je manque de concentration
de rigueur de discipline
mais sous le masque du cancre se cache
une grande réserve et oui je suis timide
sur le moment face à ces instituteurs
je ne dis rien je garde le silence mais
je pense et grandit en moi fulgurante
lui prouver qu'il a tort
à compter de cet entretien je décide de
quitter le clan des derniers de la
classe le verdict sans appel de ce
maître d'école visionnaire agit en moi
comme un révélateur je me mets écouté
religieusement tous mes professeurs je
note l'intégralité de ce qui explique en
place chaque commentaire chaque once est
utile j'étudie avec une énergie sans
limite j'arrête définitivement de
tricher en poupe
quelques mois plus tard je suis 5e choc
32 de ma classe et accessoirement je
suis admis dans un des meilleurs
collèges de mon quartier le collège que
ma mère avait choisi pour moi un collège
d'excellence à dimension internationale
vous allez me dire que j'avais atteint
mon but que j'avais fait mentir mon
maître d'école
marshall rosenberg un film que certains
mots sont des fenêtres et d'autres sont
des murs les paroles de mon instituteur
continuer à me blesser je t'ai face à un
mur imaginez la muraille de chine il me
fallait l'arpenter jusqu'au bout alors
pourquoi m'arrêter là
iliad une chose que je ne vous ai pas
dit j'aime la danse m'a un peu pas
beaucoup mais passionnément la danse
classique
le seul petit problème est que je suis
un garçon et que je viens hong kong je
peux vous jurer qu un garçon qui
pratiquent la danse classique laisse
rarement indifférent et encore moins au
coeur de la perle de l'orient où les peu
de la virilité sont à peine questionné à
aux gens j'entre tongs au collège bien
décidé à aller de l'avant aller plus
haut à faire de mon rêve une réalité ce
collège est un 40 minutes de chez moi
vers 1h15 de mon école de danse je
navigue entre ces deux établissements
cinq jours sur sept mon trajet quotidien
dure 2h30 le métro et d'un endroit assez
atypique en version dure d'études même
quand il n'y a aucune place pour
s'asseoir et j'ai fait mes devoirs ma
détermination me suis comme lieu de
marianne bienveillante et vigilance la
seule chose qui m'intéresse est ton
c'est encore et toujours le cours de
danse et mon point de mire quotidien
alors imaginez ma frustration quand la
direction du collège oblige par exemple
à rester régulièrement pour chanter dans
la chorale
face à ces nouvelles contraintes je
bouillonne mes plaintes auprès de mes
parents sont sans fin je reste année là
étudiés rêveur alors je suis aussi
régulièrement coller le système scolaire
dans lequel je me trouve assomme les
séculiers de devoir alors tu de ma
famille s'y met pour que je m'en sorte
je rage contre ces obstacles qui
entravent mon chemin
mais j'ai une deuxième à rennes cette
fameuse colère que personne ne prend le
temps d'écouter moi je les invite à
s'asseoir près de moi je les écoute elle
met clair je comprends que pour réaliser
mon rêve de faire de la danse mon métier
je dois partir ou qui fait ce collège la
pression scolaire grandissante quitter
ma famille j'étais mon pays
ma décision est prise à 13 ans je
commence mes recherches je suis devant
mon ordinateur je pianote le logo de
google s'affiche et je tape deux mots de
ce simple petit mot
aller jusqu'aux
le premier site qui apparaît sur mon
écran est celui de perez par les secours
j'en garde un souvenir précis mais je
sape l'immigration tout d'abord parce
que le site est entièrement en français
impossible pour moi de comprendre
comment postuler et envoyé ma
candidature
ensuite je suis le seul garçons de ma
classe de danse à hong kong impossible
par conséquent de connaître mon niveau
par rapport aux autres apprentis
danseurs je sens que mon entourage je
demande à mes proches les réponses se
convergent toutes dans le même sens
tu ne rentrera jamais à l'opéra tu n'as
pas le niveau ils ne prennent pas
d'étrangers et puis tu ne parle pas un
mot de français à le vivre à paris qui
était ta famille comment tu vas te
débrouiller je décide de faire fi de
toutes ces objections et de toutes ces
prédictions
en mai 2011 je prends vol direction la
france un professeur de danse ma
campagne c'est mon premier long
courriers et mon premier voyage en
dehors de l'asie je vais passer une
audition
et je suis ami
j'intègre l'école de danse de l'opéra de
paris
à la proclamation des résultats je me
souviens de cette phrase lancée à la
volée
le plus facile est fait le plus dur
reste à venir bon courage
quelques mois plus tard voilà dans
l'avion pour paris à 14 ans cette fois
ci seules chargées de deux énormes
valises
arrivée à l'aéroport charles de gaulle
pour un taxi direction de nanterre c'est
là que se situe l'école de danse je ne
parle toujours pas le français se sont
perdus ma lettre de mission indique une
chambre m'attends à l'internât je pense
donc que je peux d'ores et déjà bien
salée le taksim dvd bouche devant
l'école lester de mai volumineux bagages
je trouve porte close
la rentrée a lieu le lendemain
à mal ce premier jeu en france
je passe la nuit chez le chauffeur de
taxi
résumer mes quatre années à l'école de
temps serait une gageure tout ce que je
peux vous dire est que ma vie change
radicalement rien ne ressemble à mon
quotidien d'enfants apprentis danseurs à
hong kong je suis les programmes de
l'éducation nationale le matin je me
retrouve en classe avec des enfants de
cm1 j'avais 14 ans
l'après midi je danse au coeur de l'une
des meilleures écoles du monde le
décalage est violent et ma solitude
totale
conséquence
les insomnies rythme réduit à l'internât
moi je collectionne non plus les
mauvaises notes mais les nuits blanches
j'ai peur je suis me qualifier et vous
n'allez jamais deviner pourquoi
parce qu'il me faut jouer les fourberies
de scapin seul devant toute ma classe de
théâtre et tout cela dès les premiers
jours à l'école de danse
je ne dors pas ou plutôt je ne dors plus
alors je décide de me lever tôt à 6
heures tous les matins je me joue dans
une chambre vide et je travaille
en me réveillant plus tôt et on
travaille en une heure de plus chaque
matin je pense alors rattraper mon
retard par rapport aux autres mondes ans
comme en français
cet outil matinale fait désormais partie
intégrante de mon existence une
existence il rencontre à cette période
de ma vie l'expérience de l'arrachement
partir loin de sa famille et pour moi de
l'ordre du déracinement
mes parents ma grande sur gamecube ma
tante anne qui vivait avec nous ma grand
mère me manque terriblement
était notre 2e r pour moi et ma soeur
elle n'était pas mariée s'occuper de
nous depuis notre naissance avec un
engagement sans faille en décembre 2011
trois mois après mon arrivée en france
je rentre à la maison pour les vacances
de noël ma joie est immense bon con que
me voilà c'est comme une libération à
l'aéroport je cours vers mes parents ne
nous prônons dans les bras
apple en maintenant le distille je te
temps devant moi ma jeunesse à l'avenir
un horizon je le verrai plus tard
ces paroles tombe comme un couperet
un cancer à l'hôpital
choko presse est un fil d'ariane qui
vient d'être coupé ma vie donc on ne
sera plus jamais comme avant la maladie
elle a une sale maladie un ennemi de
plus à combattre un ennemi sans foi ni
loi
un an plus tard je traverse une partie
du globe pour me rendre au chevet de ma
tente une dernière fois toute l'école de
danse connaît le motif de mon départ il
ya plus de dix ans je me demande mais tu
es sûre qu'elle va mourir
vous devez innocence est une chance mais
sur le moment je suis incapable
d'apprécier cette vision et d'en mesurer
le sens profond
ne mourra jamais je découvre après sa
mort un catalogue de tous les articles
de presse écrit sur moi un catalogue
qu'elle gardait avec la fierté d'une
bonne fait une bonne fait qu'il soutient
indéfectiblement son protégé qui
adhèrent à tous ces projets bon retour
en france est lourd mais deux énormes
valises ne sont plus rien à côté de mon
appartement et ma tristesse qui est
immense
cette tristesse est là bien là mais
accompagnée d'une volonté farouche de
rendre fier cette femme qui a tissé pour
moi les fils de la confiance et de
l'élan alors je continue à me lever à 6
heures tous les matins à l'internât
au bout de deux années passées en france
j'obtiens mon brevet des collèges avec
mention très bien à l'examen annuel de
danse je suis premier de la classe à
l'issue de ma formation à l'école de
danse gens viennent sur le concours
d'admission au ballet de l'opéra de
paris
c'est un échec je recommence c'est
encore un échec
elle a son sourire son regard posé sur
moi d'être à la hauteur de ce regard
être à la hauteur de cette famille à
laquelle je suis fier d'appartenir
c'est tout ce qui compte pour moi
j'irai jusqu'au bout
en septembre 2015 je suis le premier
chinois à être engagés dans la compagnie
du ballet de l'opéra de paris
c'est la réalisation d'un rêve d'enfant
c'est une fenêtre qui s'ouvre là où un
instituteur avaient érigé une muraille
c'est un présent à tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu c'est une offrande à ma tante
qui habite chacun de mes pas
quand on m'a demandé de participer à 6tu
soir et je me suis demandé quelle avait
été ma manière de relier les points de
ma vie my way of kings john
toute cette aventure m'a permis de
grandir et m'a appris au moins trois
choses
premièrement les réussites se
construisent petitpas après petit pas
comme se réveiller plus tôt chaque matin
vous travaillez d'une heure de plus par
jour il suffit de faire un pas puis un
autre avec patience et conscience sans
avoir la garantie du résultat mais riche
de la confiance que nos proches de sa
corde en tout cas c'est comme cela que
j'ai pu être diplômé d'une école de
commerce tout en exerçant la profession
de danseur à l'opéra de paris
deuxièmement il faut parfois savoir
s'appuyer sur des ressources très
spécial ces émotions négatives si
décriée comme la colère ou la tristesse
si l'on prend le temps de s'asseoir
auprès d'elle et de les écouter on se
coller à ses besoins profonds et c'est
le respect de ces besoins qui va avancer
et grandir
troisièmement
nous avons tous accepté le fait qu'outre
ou de nous se trouveront toujours des
personnes aux croyances de 8 ans les
personnes là vous nous rappeler que l'on
y arrivera jamais que tout cela n'est
pas fait pour nous et pourra s'agir d'un
ancien maître d'école peut être nous
mêmes ou de n'importe qui d'autre
n'accorder aucun crédit à ces discours
réducteur tout est possible à partir du
moment où vous décidez d'aller vers ce
pour quoi vous vous êtes fait
aujourd'hui c'est dans cet état d'esprit
que je me lance dans la captivante
aventures de l'entrepreneuriat en fond
dans mon propre cabinet de conseil en
gestion de patrimoine didier aux
artistes et sportifs de haut niveau
alors je n'ai qu'une seule chose à vous
dire
fait des événements de votre vie
l'occasion d'une audience où chaque pas
compte ou chacun puis fait la différence
où chaque émotion sera le moteur de
votre liberté et de votre créativité
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]